all good things right hey there folks
it's over dude doctor who reviewed time
and this episode of council of geeks is
of course brought to you by radio versus
the Martians it's a podcast which means
it's free how awesome is that host Mike
Gillis and Casey Doran take a look at
all manner of geeky subjects whatever's
on their mind and they do it with a
revolving staple of guests they will
talk about anime they'll talk about
wrestling they'll talk about comics
movies TV sci-fi fantasy and of course
every single movie that arm
Schwarzenegger ever made yeah they were
really devoted to that one radio versus
the Martians at radio versus the
Martians calm or wherever you get your
podcast
oh so stolen earth and journey's end the
departure of Donna as the companion the
it's actually funny going back and
revisiting this two-parter because I
think in a lot of ways a surprising
amount of it doesn't really stick in my
head while other things are vividly
wrapped into my brain
the main one being circumstance the and
culmination of Donna's actual exit that
breaks my heart
massively a lot of the lead-up is kind
of just typical Davey's finale stuff
it's very big it's very operatic it's
very noisy and it just it pushes to a
very strong
emotional climax but a lot of the steps
in getting us there aren't the most
memorable things in the world and I
think that's kind of the common thread
for his finales I think that's kind of
true of series one I mean I like I
consider the entire bad wolf half of
that two-parter to not be particularly
good at all with army of ghosts and
Dukes a army of ghosts is all set up
with almost nothing being particularly
memorable and doomsday has all of the
weight in it in lasses you know sound of
drums last of the Timelords whenever
it's just the doctor the master in the
room it's electric and other than that
it's it's again it's a bit just kind of
moving us through the paces and we kind
of get that a little bit here going on -
there's still a lot to like though this
does feel in some ways like a bit of a
celebration of the reinvented Doctor Who
up to that point and a lot of that has
to do with everybody that comes back I
think this does a pretty good job of not
only bringing back you know Jack
Harkness and Sarah Jane Smith but
bringing in the cast's or at least some
of the cast from their respective
spin-off shows that were already going
on at that time so Sarah Jane Adventures
and Torchwood and making it still work
for people who had not seen those you
get enough of a sense that Jack has this
team and you know so he there's Ianto
and there's Gwen or you know Sarah Jane
gets to talk a little bit about the
computer mr. Smith and Luke her son not
a ton not a ton of time spent and
obviously if you know those shows you
know and not a lot more about these
characters but it's pretty well
integrated it doesn't feel like oh man
I'm just being dropped in the middle I
have no idea what's going on it's
surprisingly well handled that plus
bringing in just a ton of characters
besides me of Harriet Jones coming back
Rose Mickey Jackie it really is a loaded
story this one plus we're bringing back
Davros into the modern era who hasn't
been here at this point along with the
return of the Daleks Dalek Caan is back
and we're paying off so many of the
mystery boxes that have gone on this
season there
actually and there's actually quite a
few of them there well there's something
on your back I paid off last story but
other than that we've got the bees
disappearing and the planets you know
vanishing and oh and the doctor Donna
and all of this stuff all getting paid
off
so given everything this two-parters
doing it's actually kind of surprising
that it works as well as it does as much
as you know I feel like it was kind of
an odd experience watching it because a
lot of his like oh yeah that's right
there is this and that but there's also
something a little bit off and I was
gonna say it's a I'd say a little bit
off about Tennant but it's not his fault
I don't think I think it's the writing I
do think the one area that suffered by
all of the plot mechanics that are at
work in order for Davies to pull off
what he's pulling off here is that the
doctor doesn't actually get a lot to do
the doctor just kind of get shuttled
from bit to bit and without a lot of
time to pause not a lot of bits to to
pause for fun banter or you know where
he kind of takes control of the
situation he's just kind of getting
shuttled through the story and it was
occurring to me you know watching it he
just he spends a surprising amount of
time and this two-parter
just sort of standing still and like and
shouting impotently know
Davros you can't listen to me no just
listen I done he has lines like that a
lot like a lot a lot and they always
feel a little bit off another like the
first one that seems off is when Donna
brings up a pyro vial
or or paraphilia sorry is the planet
because you know she remembers from
fires of Pompeii and they're like no
that vanished thousands of years ago and
the doctor has to go oh that's brilliant
they've been taking out of time and
space and the line feels like it comes
out of nowhere and it you can it feels
like he feels awkward saying he's gonna
go thought oh that's brilliant and like
it doesn't have the flow and the and the
you know just the smooth going of their
dialogue that it usually has so I think
part of what happened here is Davies got
so focused on being sure that the plot
mechanics all worked in order to have
everyone he wanted in the story and for
it to get to where he wanted to get to
that he lost some of the flow of some of
these characters the doctor especially
it does kind of come back by the end
once you know sort of the major plot
mechanics are done being played out and
you know we've got the meta-crisis
doctor and we've got the the doctor done
and all that stuff it does sort of it
smooths out at that point but up to that
point there's a lot of surprisingly
clunky dialogue which is odd because I
don't remember that really being an
issue with too many of Davies scripts up
to this point but I didn't really kind
of jump out of me this time but that's
and that's kind of my major complaint
about this but other than that
oh yo it's it's fun to see everybody
back it is kind of really cool that you
know he gets everybody around the TARDIS
console and but they actually fly
smoothly for once because it's got as
many pilots as it's supposed to have
Julian beech does a really good job as
Davros he yeah he sells that part really
well he has the anger but he's also got
that you know the voices is really well
done they got just the right amount of
modulation on it
um I also like the supreme Dalek his
voice isn't quite as booming as the
Dalek Emperor from back in series one
but I like there's something about the
slightly bigger slightly bulky bulkier
slightly deeper voice
on the supreme Dalek that I just enjoy
so I just find entertainment and that
Donna firing off a million words a
minute
you know once once the whole dr. Donna
thing happens that's a lot of fun
the the payoff of Rose getting the
meta-crisis doctor to herself that that
was that was well done because that
whole thing could have felt like it
undermined doomsday but it didn't it
felt like look you're not gonna have
exactly what it is you want but you can
have this and I hope you can be happy
with that and that yeah that worked for
me and then of course when we get to the
end and we've got Donna realizing what's
going to happen the doctor coming to
wipe her memory and her just shaking
your head no no like she he takes her
choice away she would rather die than
forget but he doesn't let her make that
choice he makes it for her against her
wishes and I mean I I get why he doesn't
want to watch her die but he takes that
choice from her and that's a heavy
decision and it's played properly on
that front and then you know Wilf seeing
her and his face just falling that huh
that's rough going
so this thing by the very end definitely
absolutely lands its true emotional gut
punch for the end but I just I feel like
I always said that I feel like the plot
got away from Davies it didn't he
actually kept the plot in line but I
think he lost sight of some of the other
stuff that is great about Doctor Who and
Tennant's doctor and in specific and
it's just missing some of the charm I
feel like it needed like one more Polish
pass to you know button up the the
dialogue so it
feels more free-flowing feels more fun
but we don't get that what we get though
is still is still a very solid piece of
work I just wish it I just wish the
dialogue flowed better honestly that
that's just thing and it's that can feel
like a nitpick but at the same time
because you know dialogues a major
component it's something that kind of
keeps coming up across the story which
bums me out a bit I have a feeling that
when I do my ranking this this story's
probably actually gone down slightly in
my estimation because I think it's been
so long since I've rewatched all of it
that I think the stuff that really stood
out which I love and you know hurts me
in the best way than the other stuff
with Donna and you know Davros being
very memorable and stuff like that had
all kind of bubbled to the surface and
the rest I kind of fall into the
background but watching it I was like oh
yeah that's right that was a little bit
of a bummer so I have to wonder what I
make when I make criticisms like that or
people are gonna go oh yeah he's kind of
right or are they gonna go this guy he's
trying to ruin something that's awesome
making we must stop him I don't know
we'll see
I am we'll see because the comments
section so whatever your thoughts are in
this story drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it there's
other stuff to do down there as well cuz
buttons links the like button is a big
help lately folks been hitting it and I
appreciate it there's also the patreon
if you want to help support this and
make all of this better than it already
is hopefully there's other links besides
you know social media is my P o box my
book etc etc so click on the links give
them a look or don't I'm not gonna say
you have to do it because at the end of
the day folks you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]